[Music]
you know I I don't this is something a
perv but I see you every day when I come
to work because you shoot here and your
billboard is right outside the building
and it is quite yeah it's it's you with
these two dudes
it enrages me that poster I feel so
jealous on the show there's a love
triangle so you're making out with two
different guys on the show
constantly more than that I'm pretty
sure I've made out with every guy on the
show as my character of course right yes
you don't make out with them your
character does you don't go near though
the awkwardness and the weirdness is
when like my mom comes to set and I have
to do like a sex scene or something and
that can get kind of weird but what's
even weirder is when I come off set she
starts giving me notes yeah your mom
what would your mom say to you I'm just
curious oh I'm like arch your back more
like it'll look sexier out your back
that's creepy I'm sorry you're going to
be saying that stuff
zach is intrigued sorry yeah I didn't
know that yes I always I always arch
your back more I'm yeah really cool
really no really cool move with the
ladies Zach when you open your shirt to
reveal green unitard
[Laughter]